bonsoir et bienvenue sur tv fil pour
cette nouvelle édition du 7 8 une heure
pour faire le tour de l'actualité locale
en direct dès 18h en plateau chantal
paoli texier présidente d'ajc contre les
violences morales bonsoir à vous vous
êtes venu sur le plateau à l'occasion de
la journée internationale des droits des
femmes du 8 mars et du lancement de
cette opération nationale le 8 mars
c'est toute l'année initié par le
gouvernement des actions chaque jour 365
actions pour lutter contre les
inégalités et les violences le détail
dans une dizaine deux minutes et puis
nous aurons aussi ce soir une large page
consacrée à la culture avec aurélia de
bissy bonsoir aurélia comme ça il est
forcément nous sommes le mercredi nous
sommes en pleine période de vacances on
va s'intéresser aux ateliers pour les
enfants objectivement mercredi jour des
enfants traditionnellement donc nous
partirons pourtant dans cette chronique
culture donc autour des activités
spécialement dédié aux enfants et nous
recevrons pour en parler trois
représentants de lieux d'animation
inédit donc sur le bassin de saint
quentin en yvelines à savoir la ferme de
gally france miniature et le musée de la
ville de saint quentin la chronique
culture dans une vingtaine de minutes à
tout à l'heure aurélia voici à présent
les titres de ce 6 mars les sujets à
découvrir également ce soir la ligne de
train la verrière la défense réouverte
progressivement à la circulation dès ce
jeudi à une reprise partielle avant une
fin de travaux toujours prévue le 14
mars le quartier du val igloo à plaisir
est en cours de rénovation pour éviter
les tags sur les bâtiments et offrir au
quartier une vision plus artistique une
idée originale le principe des fresques
participative réalisé en partenariat
avec citécréation à un spécialiste de
l'art mural qui intervient dans le monde
entier le week end the la réouverture de
france miniature à elancourt chaque
année le site accueille 200 milles
dieter parmi elles des maquettes en
cours de réalisation elle a cité de
carcassonne et puis un atelier autour
des parfums proposés aux enfants de 8 à
11 ans cela se passe à l'osmothèque de
versailles en atelier intitulé les
petits nés et qui se déroule pendant et
hors des vacances scolaires et puis
cette information qui concerne
l'entreprise renault le plan de
compétitivité a été acceptée aujourd'hui
par les principaux syndicats cfe cgc et
force ouvrière un plan qui prévoit un
niveau de production minimum de sept
cent dix mille véhicules par an jusqu'en
2016 dont 110 milles à l'usiné de flins
dans les yvelines est la direction qui
s'engagent aussi à ne pas recourir à un
plan social malgré les 8000 260
suppressions de postes en deux ans en
échange les salariés devront travailler
plus tout en acceptant un gel de leurs
salaires en 2013 à la signature devrait
avoir lieu le 12 mars lors du comité
central de la société en revanche la cgt
reste toujours opposé à ce projet nous
reviendrons plus en détail sur les
incidences pour les sites de production
de flins et de recherche et
développement de guyancourt au cours de
nos prochaines éditions passe pour
l'instant on fait du jour le grand paris
express le verdict est tombé
jean marc ayrault s'est engagé
aujourd'hui et mercredi à la réalisation
intégrale du futur métro automatique
grand paris express en 2030 ce 2030
c'est donc le chiffre de cette édition
au total 200 km 72 nouvelle gare pour
désaturer elle les transports en commun
en ile-de-france et désenclaver des
territoires il fera d'ailleurs
dorénavant parler du nouveau grand paris
c'est le nom de ce projet qui conjugue
grand paris express mais aussi les
améliorations et des lignes existantes
qui était programmé plan unique de
travaux d qui débutera en 2015 il a été
présenté depuis marne-la-vallée devant
des élus devant des responsables
d'entreprises également nous sommes en
ligne avec robert cadalbert le président
socialiste de la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines bonsoir à vous
vous étiez présent lors du discours du
ministre en fin de journée à marne la
vallée est ce que vous êtes soulagés
déjà tout d'abord votre premier
sentiment toutes les lignes toutes les
maisons vont être réalisés d'ici à 2030
et coûtera avec force de griller le
maire depuis en converse voiture
excusez-nous que la mauvaise conditions
de l'interview il est important d'être à
quezon à vendre à l'aller parce qu'on a
pu apprendre qu effectivement toutes les
réseaux de transport et particulièrement
la
soirée a clairement car effectivement on
parle de ligne 18 à présent la femme une
ligne verte le projet rebaptisé nouveau
grand paris on parle aussi sur cette
portion qui intéresse les habitants de
saint quentin en yvelines autour de
versailles du d'un transport plus légers
aussi ce sont quelques pistes qui avait
été avancée et ce sont les pistes ont
été complétés retenu retenu
on a quand même bien sûr je suis obligé
de vous interrompre la liaison qui n'est
pas très très bonne on vous en parle
l'entente pas très très bien on essaiera
de vous avoir tout à l'heure pour avoir
votre votre sentiment de votre réaction
dans quelques minutes on vous rappellera
un peu plus tard au cours de cette
édition pour l'instant nous allons
continuer à dérouler le fil de
l'actualité du jour et nous intéresser à
la journée internationale des droits des
femmes qui sera célébrée le 8 mars